[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: Welcome to a
special episode of Chalk Radio,
a podcast about
inspired teaching at MIT
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
I'm your host Sarah Hansen.
In this episode, we want
to share some insights
into the many ways
we can transition
our traditional learning
environments into remote ones.
We connected with
someone whose work even
before the pandemic hit
has been deeply focused on
how learning is changing.
Our conversation
started off with what's
become a familiar sound for
listeners with young ones
at home.
SPEAKER 2: [children
playing, family talking].
SPEAKER 3: Well,
it looks like, ...
SARAH HANSEN: Just
so you know, you
might hear some more of
this in the background
throughout the episode.
We're all doing the best we
can working from home, right?
JUSTIN REICH: Hey, girls--
SPEAKER 2: Dance party.
SARAH HANSEN: Anyhow,
let's jump right in.
JUSTIN REICH: I'm Justin Reich.
So I'm an assistant professor
in Comparative Media Studies.
And I run a lab called
the Teaching Systems Lab.
And the mission of the
Teaching Systems Lab
is to design,
implement, and research
the future of teacher learning.
And we try to figure out
new ways for teachers
to learn in online
and blended ways.
SARAH HANSEN: In his
work, Justin partners
with teachers and instructors,
curriculum designers, software
developers, researchers, and
experts from across disciplines
to help teachers adapt to the
changing world of learning.
Since the pandemic has
shifted almost all teaching
to remote instruction,
Justin's work
has adapted to the new
needs of instructors.
JUSTIN REICH: I would say the
bulk of my teaching energy
has gone into helping K-12
educators and education
policymakers across the country.
But most of my work
has been trying
to provide some guidance for
schools and school leaders
figuring out what distance
learning can look like.
SARAH HANSEN: So for schools
and teachers with little
or even no experience
with online instruction,
where do they even begin to
approach remote learning?
With so much changing
each day, what
are the most important
things educators
should be thinking about?
JUSTIN REICH: These are
enormously complicated issues
to deal with while you're
trying to feed millions more
meals to kids than
you ever had before
in large districts or
big urban school systems
while you're trying to
help your entire faculty
transition almost
instantaneously
into a new model of learning.
I mean, doing all of these
things at the same time
is just immensely complicated.
So I would encourage
people to keep it simple.
That's one principle.
A second principle
is to really think
about how you can partner
with students and in K12
with their families.
So the coronavirus
feels like it's
something being done to us.
It feels like something that we
have very little control over.
But our response
to the coronavirus
can be something that
we build together.
So I would encourage education
leaders at every level from
college provosts to elementary
school teachers to school
principals, superintendents
-- whatever it is--
asking and partnering with
everybody in the system
is a really important part of
responding to remote learning.
What most emergency remote
learning should look like
is kind of a package of
asynchronous materials
that's coupled with lots
of frequent check-ins.
SARAH HANSEN: Synchronous
versus asynchronous teaching
or offering learning
experiences at a specific time
versus providing students
with the material
to engage with on
their own time is
at the core of Justin's
message for teachers.
JUSTIN REICH: So in
lots of circumstances,
synchronous learning is not
going to work for people.
It's hard for all of us
to line up our schedules.
In K12 circumstances, you've
got a teacher who's got a first
grader, a fourth grader, and
a seventh grader who's trying
to teach her kids who
are ninth graders,
but they have siblings or third
graders and fourth graders
and 12th graders...
and trying to line up all
those schedules so that people
can be synchronously in
front of the one computer
that exists in a household or
to use the amount of bandwidth
because your home only allows
one synchronous video call
to happen at a time, it's
just too complicated.
So for the most
part, what educators
should be thinking of setting
up is some kind of package
of curriculum that lasts
about a week or two
maybe with some sort of daily
guides of what people might
be doing each day recognizing
that people might have
to do two days of
work in one day
because they get busy with
other stuff for another day,
or things like that
and then providing
frequent points of check-in.
So a huge part of what
motivates us as learners
is when we're getting
feedback on what we're doing.
And this doesn't have to be
based around grades or numbers
or other things like that.
Just "that was a great idea.
Keep that up.
Tell me more about that."
"Wow, it looks like you
did more on this assignment
than anyone you've done before.
What else could
you do with this?
How could you take this further?
It seems like you're
interested in this."
SARAH HANSEN:
Shifting so heavily
toward asynchronous teaching
might feel strange at first.
But this one change may
address in a small way
some of the equity issues school
systems and individuals are
facing right now such
as differing access
to dependable Wi-Fi.
JUSTIN REICH: There's
no survey that
was done in advance of the
pandemic that asked questions,
like, "do you have one device
for each school-aged child
or learner in your home
and a broadband connection
and a printer to be able
to print things out?"
Like, we actually don't
know how well families
are equipped for this pandemic.
But it's pretty clear that a
lot of our low-income housing
is in broadband deserts
or isn't networked in.
I mean, there's lots of
people in urban environments
who in their typical
daily lives can
get by with having one
mobile broadband device
in their house,
and that's plenty.
But now if you've got three
school-aged kids at home,
your demands have just
increased substantially.
But I think partnering
with students,
I think, really
thinking about, who
are the most vulnerable
learners in our community?
There are some people who come
from affluent well-equipped
homes.
And they're able to weather this
crisis in a very different way
than if you're going back into
a poverty-impacted place that
is really feeling the
effects of the recession
and the coronavirus.
I think the students that
aren't reaching out--
I think the ones that
are not doing well,
I think we always had
this responsibility.
But I think during
a pandemic, we
have a special responsibility
to reach out to those students
and say, "how can I
help you with this?
How can I keep you on track?"
SARAH HANSEN: And
helping students
stay on track is another
big part of the puzzle
for a lot of educators
out there, especially
for classes that form the
foundations for later learning.
JUSTIN REICH: I mean,
I think the other thing
that universities and
other places need to do
is be strategic about
what it is that we want
students to be able to learn.
So if you were to go
across the OCW catalog,
I think you would find at
least two types of courses.
One type of course is where
to study a discipline you
sample from a canon.
So literature is the most
obvious example of this.
But I think it appears in
STEM classes and other places
as well.
If you were to take a
Shakespeare class at MIT,
you wouldn't read all
of Shakespeare's work.
You would read some selected
sample of that work.
And we would probably
be willing to say
we read Romeo and
Juliet and Twelfth Night
and a couple of
sonnets before we left.
And we were going to
do that much work again
in the fourth quarter.
But actually, this time, we're
just going to read Henry the V.
And we'll do it a
little bit more slowly.
And that'll be fine.
That is a less of a
sampling of the canon
that we would have
done previously.
But it's a perfectly reasonable
sampling of the canon.
We'll give you your
emergency pass grade.
Everything is fine.
There are other courses
in which there's
a sequential building of
material of understanding
in which subsequent courses
depend upon that sampling
understanding.
So our Introduction
to Statistics Class,
it's not suitable to
say to a student, ah,
we're just going to do half
of multiple regression.
And we're just not going
to teach you the other half
or figure it out on their own.
I mean, one of the things
that I think at the department
level or other levels
people need to do
is to say there's some courses
that we strategically reduced.
And those young people
will be fine for the rest
of their lives.
We don't have to worry about it.
There are other courses that
we had to strategically reduce
in a pandemic.
But we've got to figure
out how we support students
in learning that material
so they don't show up
at Intermediate
Statistics in the fall
without the preparation
that they need
to be successful and still,
the sort of lingering
effects of the pandemic.
So that's a kind of
strategic question.
It's probably best resolved
at the department level--
something along the lines
of, who are the students
in our core classes that we
think missed learning materials
that they really
are going to need?
And how are we going to
supplement over the summer
or right when people come
back in August or in the fall
or whatever the new model
looks like to identify
the areas in which it's not OK
to just strategically reduce.
But instead, we
got to figure out
how we help people get
the learning that they
need to be successful
in subsequent courses.
SARAH HANSEN: When
I asked Justin
about putting new teaching
approaches into practice
and developing materials
to support educators
during COVID-19, we got
to talking about education
at scale.
From the system as a whole to
each individual participant,
there's such a wide range of
needs and no one prescription
for addressing them all.
And in a time when
teachers should
be focusing on partnering
with students and families
and identifying how
to strategically
reduce and recover
content area material,
open educational resources may
have an important role to play.
JUSTIN REICH: Students differ
so much from place to place.
One of the things
that I'm seeing
is that a lot of
big districts are
creating sample lessons,
sample schedules--
those kinds of things.
But my initial evidence
is that a lot of teachers
aren't using them, not
necessarily because they're
bad or wrong, but
just because they,
like, aren't right for where
their kids are right now.
And so a lot of
teachers feel the need
to be basically inventing
their own new distance learning
curriculum as they're learning
a whole series of new practices
and co-inventing them
with their students
and finding the forty
percent of their kids
who aren't answering emails
or responding to phone calls
and facilitating their own
kids' instruction at home.
I mean, I think that's
something that people really
need to keep in mind.
But I would say that if
schools are facing waves
of closure in the fall or other
kinds of challenges like this,
I would really
encourage people to say,
even though it's not exactly the
way I would want to teach it,
there may be a better
comparative advantage
for faculty members to
focus on that check-in,
that facilitation role
rather than trying
to generate original content
by video without a studio
and without all the other
resources that we need,
or consider doing less of
that, consider saying, "oh,
in my solid state
chemistry course,
I can find these MIT
OpenCourseWare videos.
And six of the 10
lectures are great.
And I'm going to only
record four for the period
that we have to miss in the
fall" or other kinds of things
like that.
I mean, I think one of the
things that we've discovered
is that faculty find it
very difficult to identify
whole online courses that they
like to just take and sort
of use as textbooks.
But it strikes me that
a pandemic is exactly
the sort of time in which
people might want to employ
that kind of thinking.
SARAH HANSEN: One of the
most important factors
in determining our
best way forward
is looking at how
we actually measure
the success of remote learning.
Who do we look to for
guidance and models
of what is best right now?
It's not as simple
as it might seem.
JUSTIN REICH: So we
just did this report
about the remote
learning guidance offered
by all 50 states.
And one of the cautions
that we have in the report
is there are good reasons to
believe that lots of teachers
are not doing what this says,
that educational systems are
what we call loosely coupled.
So there are
tightly-coupled systems
in our society
like the military.
If a general in the military
says everyone's hair should
be shorter than x inches,
then within weeks,
there would be
hundreds of thousands
of soldiers around the
world whose hair is shorter
than those number of inches.
Teaching is not like that.
Education policymakers, leaders
all the time make edicts.
And teachers sift through them.
And they apply them as they
see fit in their own context
for a variety of reasons.
And because of the incredible
granularity of teaching,
in a lot of cases,
we just don't know
what's happening at
the classroom level.
I think most of
the places that we
say are doing a good
job of remote learning,
their primary characteristic
is that they are affluent.
One way you can do a good
job of remote learning
is have a bunch of
kids in stable homes
with broadband
internet connections
who each have their own device.
And if those conditions
exist, then you
will have a thing that looks
a lot like good learning.
If those conditions don't exist,
regardless of the heroic effort
of teachers, you'll
have things that look
like less effective learning.
The way that my colleague
Tressie McMillan Cottom
said this is like
the number one thing
that education has to reduce
inequality is the school.
The school is the
thing that we've lost.
And there's not a
mechanism to like, rapidly
make up those sort
of equalizing forces.
So that's a long way of
saying that I don't think
I know of places that
I would say, wow,
these folks are doing a really
great job addressing this.
I think one measure that people
are using to define a good job
is who can do
things most quickly?
Who can get the thing
that looks closest
to what school looked
like before up and running
the fastest?
I'm not convinced
at the end of this
that that will end up being
a good proxy for better.
SARAH HANSEN: And
in the end, it seems
like better learning while
we are at home simply
looks different than
what we're used to.
And the more we
can embrace that,
the better off we as parents,
students, and educators may be.
JUSTIN REICH: I've encouraged
both families and educators
to, if possible, not put
too much stock in trying
to recreate school at home.
There are lots of
things that schools
can do in their local
environments that
can be really hard to replicate
in a home environment.
But there's lots of learning
that can happen at home.
And what we need to
do as best we can,
cultivate and celebrate
that learning.
I was interviewed
recently by a reporter
from The Arctic Sounder, which
is the newspaper of the north
slope of Alaska--
very bad connectivity up there.
And so remote
learning is not going
to look like what it looks like
in an affluent Boston suburb.
And what a lot of teachers there
were saying is, like, look,
this is a great
time for families
to strengthen their connection
to traditional Inupiaq values.
This is a great time for kids
to learn how to cook and bake
and sew and bead and
repair snow machines
and do all the kinds of
learning that can happen really
well at home.
So I think to families
out there that
are sort of struggling
during this period,
it is totally normal to
struggle during a pandemic.
If you feel like this is hard
and is anxiety-provoking,
that is normal and lots
of people feel that way.
And I think our goals--
we can't put too much
pressure on ourselves
about keeping up and
staying up and things
like that-- think
about what can you
do to maximize the learning
and the resilience that
happens right now?
And if part of what
we do to do that is
like teach our kids
new chores, if it's
time for those nine
and 10-year-olds
to start doing their
first load of laundry,
or their six or
seven-year-olds to do
their first sink
of dishes, like,
that's great
learning too that we
can do really well at the home.
And we can probably do
some reading and some math
and some social studies and
science along the way too.
And some of that relates to
the first piece of advice
that I offered before,
which is let's partner
with our learners.
And if those learners happen
to be our own kids, so much
the better to be
partnering with them.
SARAH HANSEN: If you're
interested in learning more
about teaching remotely
during the COVID-19 pandemic,
check out Justin's
WBUR On Point interview
where he talks about how
colleges and universities are
teaching students virtually.
We've provided a link to
that in our show notes.
Justin also hosts Teach Lab,
a new podcast that explores
the art and craft of teaching.
Several of the show's
recent episodes
focus on teaching
during COVID-19.
That link can be found in
the show notes as well.
If open educational
resources are
important in your practice
of teaching or learning,
particularly now
during COVID-19, please
consider supporting the
work of MIT OpenCourseWare.
There are lots of
ways to do this.
One is simply by
listening to this podcast
and sharing it with a friend.
You can also share the OCW
website with your colleagues.
And we really love hearing
about how you use OCW materials,
because we use your
stories to inspire
others to make use of OER.
Or if you'd like to
help fund our work,
please visit our
website to make a gift.
However you can support
us, we thank you.
Until next time,
please stay safe.
I'm Sarah Hansen from
MIT OpenCourseWare.